[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors y'a des gens qui sur twitter il
faut pas jouer avec la nourriture c'est
de la nourriture périmée et c'est vrai
que il faut arrêter là de la tronche et
à quoi on va plus ça c'est sa saison le
mangera pas ça non là ils étaient
périmés puis là il est sale maintenant
beaucoup comme un meneur de quoi je vais
pas faire une allergie une allergie à
quoi deux minutes je me lavais la tête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
soit une petite radio sur les barres
j'en ai pu me sur la barge en est sûre
toute la gueule un soir merci mais alors
je vous rappelle igor et grichka
bogdanoff l'équation du bel africa merci
on y va on y va alors vous reparler de
celle qui a été élue miss casa blanca
valérie benaïm est partout sur ces huit
bientôt on va l'avoir d'inspecteur
barnaby à une mamers un truc nous tous
partout partout pareil alors là on a
connu deux tatas valérie dans touche pas
à mon poste qui était là pour rigoler
pas un mot plus haut que l'autre mais
aujourd'hui tout a changé avant tout a
changé c'est le laurier de la saison on
a découvert une nouvelle
valérie benaïm et c'est pas joli joli
elle sort les griffes depuis quelques
temps cyril hanouna remarqué quelque
chose à propos de valérie bénaïm le
dragage à l'oubli la femme qui dit ce
n'est pas la grosse tête et tu sais pas
quoi redessan sympa granby
en tout cas de l'ipad et maintenant elle
se lâche complètement elle est mariée à
vienne de taseer vous allez voir alors
petit cuisse mais elles n'hésitent plus
à montrer qu qui n'y a qu'à voir
l'obscénité qui a écrit sur son tee
shirt alors des mois ça et surtout
regarder comment elle mat le cul cul de
l'animal
renault est d'accord avec moi pour
réclamer
[Applaudissements]
mais si on sait qu'elle ne respecte même
plus le patron la preuve avec sociaux
non scandaleux qu'elles vous donnent
syrie tm on n'est pas dans votre
émission on entend toujours des tirs
alors là tu es vraiment de mauvaise foi
mon petit bonne alors tu as voulu
m'attaquer mon petit bonhomme alors
c'est mon émission là maintenant mon
petit bonheur
tonton du bétail ou bien vous le savez
vous avez joué avec pendant sept ans mon
petit bonhomme arrêtés nous faisait la
gueule et dans les insultes elles vont
encore plus loin que petit bonhomme et
on a carrément à faire un refus
caractérisé d'obtempérer
c'est scandaleux il peut en dire le
titre de cette chanson toi je vais te
dire ce que tu commences à quoi le faire
avec mon fils tu vas rencontrer maman
[Applaudissements]
on verra ça me faire aller excusez nous
on n'en parle même pas tfou toi
avec la crise il voulait animer que
c'est que la télé jamais sans benhaim
les super est ce que vous avez fait la
même réponse benjamin castadi 1 sur
mythos vous auriez dit que j'y vais
direct dans touche pas à mon poste on a
un duo comique cyril hanouna et benjamin
castaldi benjamin qui est devenu le
souffre-douleur de l'animal je les adore
oui mais c'est magnifique c'est
sympathique vous avez toujours d'attaqué
et bien sûr mais ça fera vous
connaissiez le film l'emmerdeur et
benjamin castaldi c'est l'emmerdé mon
benji même quand c'est pas lui qui fait
de mauvaise vanne et ben c'est lui qui
prend quand même c'est vraiment le fond
tu qu'est ce que c'est vous allez vous
devoir vous n'êtes pas de rolex orthez a
sorti qu'un seul argument anormal ans et
numéro de téléphone mobile j ai même
quand on est censé dévoiler celui de
josé garcia il se passe quoi le numéro
josé passé et quand il faut choisir un
volontaire pour aller se prendre des
tentes dans la gueule
cyril est choisie qui en premier qui
peut démarrer et comme il au régime
benji ne peut plus manger tard mais
heureusement il peut encore s'en prendre
[Applaudissements]
venez vous faire chier dessus par le
groupe contador
c'est mon ami c'est un bon ami à moi
thierry suis très content comme ça mais
ça va changer
non il énervé en ce moment des débats
mais je serai toujours là pour nous
c'est bien pourquoi parce qu'il a un
espace sait maintenant qui va poser ses
cartons jaunes mais s'il te plait je
vous ai dit de baisser leurs regards
c'est quoi le bail la baisse ton regard
hockey non tu avais c'est ton slip ton
slip d'accord
ensuite je serai sincères et sûrement
beaucoup de comptes bagarres
on compte aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de
m'intéresser aux 40 animateurs de sa
génération en tout cas selon lui même
matthieu delormeau qui devait l'amener à
17 heures j'ai appris qu'ils seraient
pas là mais on va voir vous allez voir
personne ne le sait mais présente une
émission de vendredi
ça s'appelle tpm people c'est une
émission de débat qui est entre
l'émission politique de france 2 et
souffre
vous allez voir vous allez voir un poids
beaucoup mathieu est entouré de
paparazzi de spécialistes people et de
donner le morro je remets en matière de
leurs moules l'orée de l'élève qui veut
dépasser le maître hanouna mais siri je
pense que vous êtes peinard absolument
qu'on sache que son émission qui relie
délatté le leader et des chroniqueurs
préférés
6ème peu de leaders cmt et bafouillé
sans arrêt très bien donc je dis les
pots cassés but où se succèdent en face
à la polémique de la semaine date paul
dini des semaines c'est les stars grâce
si tu peux et manchons micropénis s'il
te plaît on peut être leader tnt pas
fouillé et en plus se tromper dans ses
lancements de séquences on va parler de
n'diaye et johnny hallyday jingle
aiacciu
[Musique]
et d'ailleurs pas du tout chaud à parler
de meghan markle skis mais dans cette
émission c'est qu'on retrouve le la
patte de l'ormeau à base de
bienveillance et de gentillesse
nationale dans le dos tellement vidé
tirer bat pour filles ça te faire tout
drôle que tu seras dans williams à midi
et berlin souhaitaient pas que tarissent
pas ce que tu vois ça arrête tu es allée
jean rapp le damian c'est dommage mais
pour parler des fours à micro on est
dégoûtés trop sucrés pour les enfants
[Applaudissements]
c'est drôle c'est tranquille mais je
n'ai pas de souci là les droïdes on voit
là effectivement les fans de foot
reconnaissent la main de dieu de
maradona
désormais il a la main de baba à vous
ferez vous de cette vidéo derrière moi
fabuleux moment où avec sa main cyril
hanouna balance doc gynéco la police
dans l'andra sera et bien j'ai encore
une fois décidé de vous insérer dans les
films c'est que oui oui et oui c'est le
grand retour du cinéma de baba
les gars écoute les procurer dans les
bons jours il jouera un gosse mais c'est
pas beau jeu je me suiciderai avant de
le faire avant tennis qu'est ce que
justin conn d'accord pour la sortir
dommage a beaucoup insisté sur le fait
que quelqu'un a cure et moi je vais
prendre mon paris brest et puis on va à
l'hôtel garçon j'ai demandé pourquoi il
m'a répondu que c'était désolé mais que
vous avez obligé de donner le dernier un
habitué
patience avait repères en rentrant
garçons font par israël
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]